this video was made possible by nordvpn
go to nordvpn.com forward slash vpn to
get a two-year plan at a super discount
more on that in a moment
[Music]
let me ask you a question that more than
one of you may have wondered at some
point would it be possible for the main
countries of the middle east to put
aside their differences once and for all
and agree to organize a common defense
with respect for example to iran
something like a sort of arab nato or a
military alliance that could even
include israel does this sound like a
crazy idea well pay close attention to
this news story
israel confirms regional military
project showing its growing role the
israeli defense minister benny gantz
said israel was working with other
countries in the middle east to combat
iranian military threats
israel works with arab allies to down
drones in sign of growing ties the
destruction of iranian drones last year
was an early example of a new regional
military project that president biden is
trying to shore up during his middle
east visit surprising as it may seem
many in washington are rubbing their
hands together over this possibility for
example with such an organization the
pentagon could concentrate on its real
priority the asia-pacific region iran
would largely cease to be a headache the
oil fields would be much better
protected and the middle east would
probably end up becoming a much more
stable place and don't forget for a
minute that we are talking about a
region that however you look at it
continues to play a key role in the
global economy for starters the region
continues to produce more than 30 of all
the oil consumed in the world
however so far and with the exception of
the new israeli project promoted by the
united states of which very few details
are known the truth is that trying to
forge some kind of military alliance in
this region of the world has never been
a simple matter in fact in the past
there have only been one or two attempts
at something similar there is for
example the case of the central treaty
organization sento an attempt in the
mid-20th century to create a nato in the
islamic world between turkey iraq and
iran along with other countries which
did not even take shape but take note
because not all of the attempts have
been a total fiasco
the gulf cooperation council which is
primarily an economic and commercial
alliance between almost all of the
countries in the arabian peninsula also
has a military arm the peninsula shield
force a military force of some 40 000
troops designed to strengthen deterrence
and improve protection and coordination
between member countries a force that
has already been deployed on one
occasion or another for example in
kuwait in 2003 just before the iraq war
and in 2011 when at the request of the
burani government this force was
deployed to quell a civilian uprising
another example we could give is the
case of the arab league which in 2015
created a small joint force of 40 000
soldiers also with the aim of responding
to possible crises and member states
however in this case we are talking
about an underdeveloped arrangement with
poorly integrated forces but beyond
these limited examples in terms of
capability integration and operational
capacities the truth is that until now
large-scale joint defense in the middle
east has been unthinkable but wait a
minute because what we're about to tell
you in this video could either be the
attempt to create the seed of a new arab
nato or just another failure in this
goal of making the security of the
middle east their own but do you want to
know what exactly we're talking about of
course you do so let's get cracking but
before we do let me tell you about
today's sponsor nordvpn we spend a good
deal of our lives on the internet in
fact it's estimated the average american
spends about 21 years of his or her life
online and if you are watching us from
down under the figure then exceeds a
whopping 27 years the point is and this
should really come as no surprise the
internet is not a safe space a few
minutes of using public wi-fi at your
local cafe and a cyber criminal knows
your credentials nordvpn helps you
reclaim your privacy it encrypts your
connection to the internet so no one can
eavesdrop on the website you visit or
the data you share it also hides your ip
addresses and location so snoopers can't
track you down and not only that
remember that when you're using nordvpn
you can browse without borders choosing
from over 5000 ultra fast servers in 58
countries all around the world this
unlocks a whole world of content that
you can't access with a standard
provider connection but is browsing
speed affected while using a vpn well
you don't have to worry about that with
nordvpn as it is the world's fastest vpn
according to an independent study by av
test what's more you can use it on all
types of devices android windows mac and
linux and with the same account you can
include up to six different devices
don't wait any longer go to nordvpn.com
forward slash vpn and get a two-year
plan for the price of one soda a month
and if you change your mind after trying
it don't worry nordvpn has a 30-day
money-back guarantee and now let's get
cracking
[Music]
check out this 2018 news item
us begins talks with the arab officials
over nato style regional alliance you
see visualpolitik fans iran's increased
belligerence and its nuclear program
that threatened and still threatens to
turn into an atomic power coupled with
its considerable ballistic technology
and relatively strong military has put
the major arab nations of the sunni
branch of islam on alert
[Music]
you see as many of you already know
there are two major religious branches
in islam the sunnis whose regional
powers are saudi arabia and the united
arab emirates and the shiites whose most
dominant power is iran well the sunni
countries most of them close to the west
have been thinking for some years that
perhaps it is time to seek protection
and cooperate with each other in order
to face an iranian threat
[Music]
but the most curious thing is not this
but above all it is the nation that is
playing a leading role in getting
countries such as saudi arabia the
united arab emirates bahrain kuwait and
egypt to smooth things over in order to
deal with the iranian threat and
islamist terrorism and keep in mind we
are not talking about an insignificant
challenge
[Music]
the countries of the arabian peninsula
excluding yemen spend about 120 billion
dollars a year on defence a budget that
almost equals that of the united kingdom
france and germany combined a budget
that is also equivalent to almost half
of china's entire military spending so
it's hardly a trivial matter well the
country that is trying to bring the
major heavyweights of the arab world
together to push for a military alliance
even putting itself in the middle is
none other than israel but wait wait
wait israel the same israel that the
arab countries themselves have been
targeting for years is this some kind of
joke well as surprising as it may seem
to you the truth is that no this is no
joke it is incredible how the tables
have turned in a matter of a few years
1948 56 67 73 82 during all these years
in one way or another directly or
indirectly various arab states were at
war or in a deadly confrontation with
israel countries like egypt and jordan
were at war with the jewish state on
several occasions for various reasons
and the vast majority of our countries
that did not go to war with israel not
only did not view it favorably but
refused to recognize it as a state
financed the palestinian struggle and
instigated trade blockades and economic
punishments of all kinds against this
country
[Music]
but visualpolitik fans all of that has
now changed radically not only is israel
no longer the enemy of the arab world
but for a certain vein of the arab world
israel is even becoming a valuable ally
in which to consider military agreements
because don't forget that israel not
only has one of the most effective and
technologically advanced militaries in
the world but it is also a nuclear
superpower check this out
[Applause]
a negev nato
[Music]
if there is one thing that seems endemic
in the islamic world is the inability to
reach major collective agreements and if
it is in matters of defense or security
things get even more complicated to this
day each and every attempt to ruin this
direction has been met with a harsh
reality of this region a region where no
one trusts anyone hold on though because
we could be on the verge of a turning
point here
the negev summit furthers arab israeli
normalization the homegrown talks signal
growing regional ties despite lack of
progress on two-state solution
israel expresses interest in nato-like
mid-east alliance now what on earth is
this negev summit well it was basically
a summit that took place on the 27th and
28th of march 2022 in the gev israel
between representatives of the united
arab emirates bahrain egypt morocco and
the united states the aim was to bring
israel and the arab countries closer
together a new step in advancing the
abraham accords
because it turns out that israel is
developing very good relations with the
arab countries with which it is reaching
agreements of all kinds and particularly
with the united arab emirates a country
with which relations are becoming very
close indeed this is allowing as we saw
in the beginning of the video even close
military ties to develop do you remember
this news item
israel confirms regional military
project showing its growing role the
israeli defense minister benny gantz
said israel was working with other
countries in the middle east to combat
iranian military threats israel wants to
play a fundamental role in leading a new
regional bloc today is the best prepared
country in the region to stop or at
least deter tehran it is one of the best
armed forces in the world and its
military industry is at the forefront of
technology now as i said before all this
talk of pushing for a grand military
alliance in the region is nothing new
[Music]
the obama administration was eager to
escape from the middle east once and for
all there were those who began to assess
this option and then later the trump
administration especially mike pompeo
promoted the so-called middle east
strategic alliance or mesa an
organization that sought to achieve
greater military coordination between
the countries of the gulf cooperation
council egypt jordan and the united
states itself however while mesa has
been put on standby with the change of
administration in the united states the
negev summit which from now on will
become an annual event does generate a
lot of hope particularly because of the
presence of israel and because the
united states seems determined to assume
a much more distant role with regard to
the problems in this region
what's more an alliance that included
israel could work not only in the
military field but also in the security
field and that that could change a lot
of things in the middle east this new
organization could not only prevent
attacks from iran the cooperation could
go much further including things such as
the security of the water supply the
intensive use of special cores and the
prevention of civil wars through the use
of peacekeepers of course it is one
thing to want it and it's quite another
to actually get it
shambles the usual shambles
[Music]
it is no secret getting the arab world
to agree on major issues is more
complicated than getting vladimir putin
himself to see reason and keep this in
mind if reaching a military alliance in
asia is already complicated imagine what
it means to do it in a region where the
religious question runs through
everything and where military and
security matters the interests of the
various royal houses often outweigh the
general interest but perhaps the biggest
stumbling block remains saudi arabia
relations between riyadh and jerusalem
have improved greatly but they remain
far more stagnant than those israel has
managed to develop with other arab
countries for example riyad has not yet
established formal diplomatic relations
and has decided not to pay much
attention to the abraham accords so the
thought of a military or security
alliance seems unthinkable today and of
course for such an alliance to go ahead
without its participation would not be
acceptable to the house of saud either
among other things this would mean
losing its leadership role in the arab
world that is to say it is basically
stuck on the fence and that's not the
end of it
[Music]
qatar which is also a member of the gulf
cooperation council gets along terribly
with the united arab emirates has
turbulent relations with saudi arabia
and is progressively improving its
bilateral relations with iran firstly
because it scares large oil fields with
iran and secondly because doha hopes to
become something of a link between
tehran and washington
qatar's ambassador to iran highlights
growing bilateral relations
qatar's foreign minister rules out
normalization with israel in the end
these are the major stumbling blocks and
perhaps the full plans will never go
ahead but today we already know that
there is a military structure operating
an alliance between israel and the arab
countries that and the israeli
authorities have the ambition to play a
much more prominent role in the middle
east and that ambition visualpolitik
fans is no small matter that said the
questions are now over to you do you
think we'll ever see a nato-style
military alliance in the middle east
what do you think israel's role in
military matters may become following
the abrahamic chords and the negrev
dialogues leave us your opinion below in
the comments and if you like this video
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
so you won't miss any of our upcoming
news once again thank you for being
there and watching us all the best i'll
see you next time
[Music]
you